my name is Lorna Lewis drummer composer
educator and today I've been challenged
to go through the levels of complexity
at the drum kit
[Music]
this instrument has existed for over a
hundred years there have been tons of
interpretations on it just for today
though we're going to hang out in my
world I'm going to go through my
interpretation of complexity on the
drums so level one is the bass drum
that's a little bit of a precursor we're
dealing in four four times what that
really explains is the value of the note
and how many of those quarter notes
exist in the bar I like to put the bass
drum on one and three that's how we're
going to start
[Music]
level two we're gonna add the snare drum
I like to consider the snare drum the
BackBeat that's a very common phrase
that you'll hear in drumming it's
similar to clapping we're going to put
the snare drum or your clapping on beat
two and beats four and that sounds like
this
[Music]
let's take it up a notch level three the
hi-hat
this is a really interesting kit piece
meaning one of the parts of the drum kit
and for the hi-hat it's something that
you can do consistently we're going to
actually play the hi-hat on all four
quarter notes now let's put it all
together
[Music]
all together you call that a Groove
another term for that is a drum pattern
I'm going to play two grooves one is a
funk groove I will evolve into that and
the next one's a rock Groove which I
will also evolve into
[Music]
thank you
you may have noticed with the hi-hat you
were hearing a really sloshy extended
sound that was actually being achieved
by me raising my left foot just a little
bit which allows the symbols to spread
apart
and gives them that shimmering sizzling
sound so when I say open hi-hat
when I say closed hi-hat
all right beats that we've been hearing
are these quarter notes and I'm playing
what are called additional eighth notes
but I'm accenting those as well
in Funk you'll probably hear more of a
tighter hi-hat sound with rock however
you will hear more open hi-hat
throughout the groove as your constant
pattern when you're dealing with funk is
a term called on the one which means
you're putting the emphasis on that
downbeat which is with the bass drum
rock also shares that but it's a little
more evenly spaced in terms of the
energy that you're putting on all of
those beats so one emphasizes the
downbeat one Smooths it out and you have
clear sailing from top to bottom it
might feel like it's a completely
different style but they are neighboring
Styles and the complexity might just be
in the way that you play them but the
patterns themselves aren't always more
complex in one way than another to help
us lock in this groove a little bit more
we should add some music this is a song
of mine called change your mind it's a
little bit faster get ready let's go for
a ride
foreign
[Music]
let's move on level five rudiments
rudiments are a grouping of notes or
rhythms that are also defined by what we
like to call stickings mentions of when
you play your right hand versus your
left hand the single stroke is a
consistent set of notes alternating
between your right hand and your left
hand now double Strokes are two hits per
hand
is a grouping of notes which is a right
left right right
these four notes can also be played the
opposite way left right left left now a
little bit faster for the right-handed
and left-handed paradiddle alternating
back and forth
you can actually create a little more of
an expression with what you're playing
by adding accents accents are when you
are playing one note louder than another
I'm going to put the two paradiddles
together now I'm going to be accenting
the first note of each group of four
notes then the second time around I'm
going to Accent the second note of each
grouping of four notes
foreign
[Music]
I just want to talk a little bit about
the hi-hat bark
where we are lifting our foot up hitting
the hi-hat and then closing our foot
right back down again
this takes the level of coordination
because you need to time when you're
opening your hi-hat or when you're
lifting your foot up against when you
hit the hi-hat I could do it the other
way around where I hit the hi-hat and
then lift my foot but it won't be the
same effect so you lift your foot strike
the hi-hat and then bring your foot back
down you can also do that in a variety
of times so you can make it longer or
extremely short
but you can make it a little more
complex by adding another counter Rhythm
or syncopation let's say on your hi-hat
or on your bass drum or even on your
snare drum now a syncopation is when you
accent something that's other than these
strong beats or the average beats that
you'd play in a bar
let's put it all together next level
more complex grooves
[Music]
now the group that you just heard was
similar to the pattern that we've
learned already but I've actually added
a couple of elements and I'm going to
break it down let's see what we get
so for the most part I was playing one
and three on the bass drum
played an open hi-hat on the downbeat
there was another skip note or added
16th note that I was playing just before
I played the downbeat I've also played
some other rhythms or syncopations on
the bass drum using syncopation you can
create elaborate rhythms or even very
simple rhythms that complement any drum
group that you're playing
[Music]
snuck a paradiddle in there right hand
on the hi-hat left hand on the snare
[Music]
Next Level polyrhythms now polyrhythms
is next in the level of complexity
really because it takes just a little
bit more than a level of our
understanding of coordination a
polyrhythm is actually two rhythms
layered on top of each other it makes a
really interesting pattern that you hear
overall the most standard version of a
polyrhythm you'll hear is the three over
two
[Music]
another one is the four over three so
I'm going to go from two over three and
then I'm going to go to four over three
[Music]
a little more complex this one is going
to be five over four
[Music]
now for the purpose of making sure that
we understand what this sounds like in a
musical context we're going to add the
music again
[Music]
next level
orchestration which by the way is just
me taking a rhythm and putting one of my
hands on a different part of the drum
set but playing the same Rhythm sidebar
four-way Independence four-way
coordination all of your limbs are
playing different rhythms its multiple
rhythms happening on multiple kit pieces
at the same time
foreign
base through the Rhythm
through rudiments
polyrhythms
you can take all of those levels and you
could re-orchestrate anything that we've
done so far if you remember our
paradiddle from earlier I'm going to
play it on the snare drum I'm going to
take my right hand and I'm going to
continue with that concept moving my
right hand around to different parts of
the drum kit first time second time this
other drum that I have here which is a
snare drum my floor tom and of course we
can't forget the rest of the kit crash
cymbals I have another one that's a
similar crash symbol has a bunch of
holes in it so if I play it very lightly
I get a really nice Sizzle this is
called a splash
this is a trash former on top and I have
another Splash underneath it as well
here's another stack over here the
symbol sandwich three symbols here one
on top is a 16 inch symbol the one all
the way on the bottom is a 14 inch China
and in the middle is a really
interesting looking symbol that has a
lot of little holes in it has a really
nice trashy rattly sound like this
and you can't forget the ride symbol
now let's put this drum kit to good use
paradiddle reorchestrating right hand
moving around to the different kit
pieces
[Music]
and now gotta have some music moving the
paradiddle around adding a little more
spice
[Music]
good
beauty of orchestration is that it gives
you a ton of options without needing to
change too much rhythmically or with the
rudiments that you're actually playing
it actually moves you right into the
next level which is drum fills
[Music]
a drum fill happens somewhere on the
drum kit that takes you into another
section of a song or helps to elevate
the energy sometimes it helps to bring
the energy a little bit lower any of the
things that we've discussed before you
can actually make those happen as drum
fills I'm gonna play a drum Groove and
near the end of the drum Groove before I
stop I'm going to play a drum fill
thank you
here's another example of that
and the third option because why not
[Music]
That's The Power of drum fills the first
one was probably a little more complex
in terms of it had more rhythms going on
the second one didn't have as many
rhythms and it stayed on a couple of Kit
pieces
and of course the last fill that I did
was really sparse
[Music]
meaning there wasn't a lot of
information a lot of drumming happening
and it gave that sense of going down a
gear or we were about to get a little
bit slower now for something a little
more advanced a 30 second note drum fill
[Music]
here's another option A Little More wild
some crashes sprinkle some stuff around
[Music]
moving on from drum fills we have
embellishments
some people might think embellishments
belong just a little bit earlier but I
actually like to add embellishments or
ornamentation after understanding drum
fills when you know how to play a drum
fill you can always push the envelope
and embellish a certain part of the drum
fill it's really just that added
expression to the moment to take it up
another notch I'm actually going to
level up a drum pattern into a drum fill
with more embellishments as I go along
foreign
there was a lot of improvised
information and playing happening I
started out with a main pattern and the
type of things that I did were to break
up the monotonous flow
[Music]
so now I'm adding a really interesting
element maybe on the hi-hat there was
some activity that happened on the bass
drum
from there I started adding some tongs
Point you're getting more energy more
excitement
and I'm adding bits and pieces adding
symbols adding Toms it's getting even
bigger to the point where you may not
even recognize the original pattern but
now we are adding to the story we're
adding to the excitement and take you
even higher and higher and higher until
you get lost inside of all of it
I'm gonna try it again but this time I'm
going to put a little more emphasis on
some of the lower drums I'm going to do
what's called grounding the pattern in a
different way by accenting rhythms that
feel like they're connected to the
stronger beats that we've been hearing
whether it's speed one two three or four
here we go
foreign
[Music]
I was grounding the overall pattern by
playing eighth notes on the floor toms
so that you felt this really big uh
having lower tones at that part of the
beat was a really cool embellishment and
helped to ground what you were hearing
then anything I added whether it was
Toms or hi-hat these were all rhythms
that took me towards these bigger
embellishments eventually I changed the
bass drum pattern so now the core drum
pattern felt a little bit different but
it had the same Spirit let's pull it all
together you got grooves polyrhythms
four-way coordination
[Music]
Embellishments
demonstration
so many of these things are going to
come together in a drum solo what you're
about to hear is the last and final Vamp
section of change your mind going into
the drum solo
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
that's definitely one way to level up
your heart rate my goodness
Pro tip make sure you're breathing when
you're playing the drums one thing I've
come to appreciate about the levels of
complexity of the drums is that once I
understood from drumming how to find my
voice I realized that I didn't have to
always be complex I didn't have to
always play really fast because the
purpose for me is to drive home a story
or drive home a feeling the art is in
the way that you can hang left right or
go straight through all of these levels
of complexity I hope you learned
something and if you didn't you better
hit rewind and make sure you go out and
learn how to express yourself
levels to this thing
[Music]
foreign